thank you
[Music]
up until about 20 years ago tiny
computers smartphones instant messaging
and video conferencing were all fanciful
science fiction inventions now they're
so ubiquitous we hardly give them a
second thought
most of these Technologies are good for
mankind but as with everything it can be
misused and turned into nefarious Tech
that can haunt us our entire lives
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
technology has leaped forward from the
transistor radio to cell phones and
satellite communication weapons have
advanced as well as surveillance systems
today anyone can have their 15 minutes
of fame just by streaming a video of
themselves worldwide
we get our news instantly we can talk
globally to anyone and we have medical
inventions to make our lives better but
in the hands of scrupulous people these
same Technologies can be used to track
our every move motivate us to vote in a
specific Direction invade our bodies and
spy on us
[Music]
we have become dependent on the
Technologies we take for granted and
those Technologies are poised to take
over the world we live in and perhaps
make us their minions
one of the most relevant theories is
that artificial intelligence May one day
take over the world an AI takeover is a
hypothetical scenario in which
artificial intelligence becomes the
dominant form of Intelligence on Earth
with computers or robots effectively
taking the control of the planet away
from the human species
possible scenarios include replacement
of the entire human Workforce take over
by a super intelligent Ai and the
popular notion of a robot uprising some
public figures such as Stephen Hawking
and Elon Musk have advocated Research
into precautionary measures to ensure
future super-intelligent machines remain
under human control
the AI Control problem is the issue of
how to build a super intelligent agent
that will Aid its creators and avoid
inadvertently building a super
intelligence that will harm its creators
some Scholars argue that solutions to
the control problem might also find
applications in existing non-super
intelligent AI
major approaches to the control problem
include alignment which aims to align AI
gold systems with human values and
capability control which aims to reduce
an ai's system's capacity to harm humans
or gain control
an example of capability control is to
research whether a super intelligent AI
could be successfully combined in an AI
box according to Bostrom such capability
control proposals are not reliable or
sufficient to solve the control problem
in the long term but may potentially act
as valuable supplements to alignment
efforts
physicist Stephen Hawking Microsoft
founder Bill Gates and SpaceX founder
Elon Musk have expressed concerns about
the possibility that AI could develop to
the point that humans could not control
it with Hawking theorizing that this
could spell the end of the human race
Stephen Hawking said in 2014 that
success in creating AI would be the
biggest event in human history
unfortunately it might also be the last
unless we learn how to avoid the risks
Hawking believed that in the coming
decades AI could offer incalculable
benefits and risks such as technology
outsmarting financial markets out
inventing human researchers out
manipulating human leaders and
developing weapons we cannot even
understand
in January 2015 Nick Bostrom joined
Stephen Hawking Max teaguemark Elon Musk
Lord Martin Reese Jan tallin and
numerous other AI researchers in signing
the future of Life institute's open
letter speaking to the potential risks
and benefits associated with artificial
intelligence
[Music]
the signatories believe that research on
how to make AI systems robust and
beneficial is both imported And Timely
and that there are concrete research
directions that can be pursued today
[Music]
foreign
autonomous car is a vehicle that is
capable of sensing its environment and
navigating without human input and many
such vehicles are being developed but as
of May 2017 automated cars permitted on
public roads are not yet fully
autonomous they all require a human
driver at the wheel who is ready at a
moment's notice to take control of the
vehicle
among the main obstacles to widespread
adoption of autonomous vehicles are
concerns about the resulting loss of
driving related jobs in the road
transport industry
on March 18 2018 the first human was
killed by an autonomous vehicle in
Arizona by an Uber self-driving car
self-driving cars combine a variety of
sensors to perceive their surroundings
such as radar lidar sonar GPS odometry
and inertial measurement units Advanced
Control Systems interpret sensory
information to identify appropriate
navigation paths as well as obstacles
and relevant signage
[Music]
connected vehicle platoons and long
distance Trucking are seen as being at
the Forefront of adopting and
implementing the technology
PC Magazine defines a self-driving car
as a computer-controlled car that drives
itself the union of concerned scientists
states that self-driving cars are cars
or trucks in which human drivers are
never required to take control to safely
operate the vehicle also known as
autonomous or driverless cars they
combine sensors and software to control
navigate and drive the vehicle
possible technological obstacles for
automated cars are artificial
intelligence is still not able to
properly function in chaotic inner city
environments
a car's computer could potentially be
compromised as could a communication
system between cars a car could be
hacked and turned into a weapon
susceptibility of car sensing and
navigation systems to different types of
weather such as snow or deliberate
interference included jamming and
spoofing
avoidance of large animals requires
recognition and tracking and Volvo found
that software suited to Caribou deer and
Elk was ineffective with kangaroos
autonomous cars may require very high
quality specialized maps to operate
properly where these Maps may be out of
date they would need to be able to fall
back to reasonable behaviors
competition for the radio spectrum
desired for the car's communication is
an issue
field programmability for the systems
will require careful evaluation of
product development and the component
supply chain and current road
infrastructure may need changes for
automated cars to function optimally
one may bring up the adage just because
you can do a thing doesn't mean that you
should do a thing people are wary of
self-driving cars and often don't trust
them due to this and Technology factors
we may be a long way off from seeing a
day when all cars are self-driving
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
science fiction we often see the use of
nanotechnology tiny robots that can
enter the body and repair cells or
accomplish cures to a disease but
nanoparticles have been around since the
50s and recent advancements makes this
something we will see more of today and
in the future
there are several dangers with this kind
of Technology though
nanoparticles are likely to be dangerous
for three main reasons
nanoparticles may damage the lungs we
know that the ultra fine particles from
diesel machines power plants and
incinerators can cause considerable
damage to human lungs this is both
because of their size as they can get
deep into the lungs and also because
they carry other chemicals including
metals and hydrocarbons in with them
nanoparticles can get into the body
through the skin lungs and digestive
system this may help create free
radicals which can cause cell damage and
damage to the DNA there's also concern
that once nanoparticles are in the
bloodstream they'll be able to cross the
blood-brain barrier
the human body has developed a tolerance
to most naturally occurring elements and
molecules that it has contact with it
has no natural immunity to new
substances and is more likely to find
them toxic
there's also the introduction of
nanoparticles or technology that could
be injected into a person allowing other
Technologies to track them
these particles can also be sprayed or
introduced into the environment on the
battlefield to track whole armies or
attack them the particles then may harm
anyone in that environment
though there are positive uses for
nanotechnology such as in the medical
field the introduction of any foreign
technology into the body can be very
dangerous
vaccines with nanotechnology May attack
a virus but also harm healthy cells
within the body or may be used to track
the individual who accepted the vaccine
they can be triggered to make you get
sick even kill you
[Music]
nanotechnology is already a huge
industry with billions of dollars being
spent on research and development
worldwide there's still a great deal to
learn about both the potential benefits
and risks of the technology nevertheless
most experts agree that the use of
nanotechnology in electronics the
pharmaceutical industry and in areas
such as Medical Imaging is outstripping
our understanding of the OHS risks
nanotechnology could lead to significant
developments in medicine manufacturing
and Computing however it may also bring
significant new health hazards
[Music]
tracking American citizens has become a
major issue in the past decade with the
emergence of drones both in the military
and corporate world at almost any given
time wherever you are it is likely a
camera is recording your movements
especially in a city
the combination of surveillance drones
and facial recognition has made this
much easier
even commercial toy drones have the
ability to follow you simply by looking
at you drones have been used to
intentionally cause harm it's the most
dangerous because they're the bad actors
that have nefarious intentions
drones are being used for illicit
activities which include but are not
limited to transport of illegal drugs
dropping leaflets into NFL stadiums
dropping contrabands such as drugs cell
phones cigarettes and weapons into
prison yards and in some cases carrying
weapons
in one case a drone helped an inmate
escape from a correctional facility
to further validate the concerns the U.S
military has identified a number of ways
that commercial off-the-shelf drones
have been weaponized with intentions to
attack U.S warfighters or military bases
overseas
there are two other complications when
it comes to addressing potential drone
threats first there's a combination of
21 Federal rules and regulations
prohibiting the use of counter drone
technology
the second issue is that until recently
drones were not required to be
registered and there is a large number
of unregistered drones which make it
extremely difficult to identify the
Drone pilot
this is especially important to identify
friend from foe additionally there is no
single counter drone technology that
addresses all the various drone
Technologies one obvious consideration
is understanding the implications of
taking down a drone while flying over
people and the possible injury to those
people
drones can also be used to spy on you
and combined with other Technologies
such as listening devices and IR
scanners they can watch you and record
your movements
every new technology comes with the
possibility of being used for
undesirable or dangerous purposes the
future of drones will require a balance
between enabling drones for good
countering drones for bad and a
comprehensive air traffic management
system that encompasses manned and
unmanned aircraft
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
protesters in Hong Kong are taking
Extraordinary Measures to protect their
identities that's because facial
recognition Technologies in China have
been used to surveil and detain people
suspected of crimes in the region
having their faces recognized by cameras
could have devastating consequences for
protesters
protesters are using various techniques
to throw off facial recognition cameras
including lasers that the cameras can't
process or recognize full coverage gas
masks and earwear they have put up
umbrellas around cameras to block them
and even torn down facial recognition
Towers
facial recognition is a polarizing topic
and is sometimes seen as a problematic
development in surveillance capitalism
people generally don't give permission
or even know they're being tracked they
also don't know how their faces are
being used
for example when you walk into most
retail stores there is a security camera
there to ward off theft however that
camera could be doing much more than
warding off theft it could use your face
for other databases so the store can
Market to you and build a behavior
profile that links your in-store
activity with your online activity
think about how Amazon built its facial
recognition technology it curated photos
of your online profiles and your
shopping experiences as well as images
from its ring doorbell Security
application and put together a profile
of you
so is security worth giving up your
privacy the problem is that facial
recognition software is calibrated to
white men therefore it misidentifies
people of color and especially women of
color at alarming rates increasing the
risk that certain groups will be
incorrectly associated with crimes
currently there are no transparent rules
on how facial recognition data can be
used and how it can be shared in some
cases it has been ruled as lawful it's a
lot to hand over your face to unlimited
entities who have not figured out the
rules for using that data
we may never reach the place where our
faces determine our social standing as
is the case in Hong Kong but will it
determine our credit ratings our job
prospects these are degrees of invasion
that are still possible
it's time to protect your privacy like
you were protesting against an
authoritarian government think of it as
if your life and the lives of your
family and friends depends on it not to
suggest you walk around with masks on
all day but be more diligent about what
you post online
share photos and videos of family and
friends on a secure network understand
that when you buy personal assistant
devices you're giving up intimate
details about yourself your family and
your friends and you have no
transparency on how those intimate
details are being shared or used
put covers on your device cameras and
only uncover them when you're using the
camera
you can't stop cameras from picking up
your face and storing it but you can
take control whenever possible
businesses and organizations also have
an obligation to their users and
customers to protect their rights
privacy is one of those fundamental
rights one that we should enjoy in our
digital world as well as in our physical
one
without the protection of those rights
around technology like facial
recognition we may end up in a place
both as businesses and individuals where
there is no escape from surveillance
and that sort of dystopia is not the
world we want to live in
there should be more regulation around
facial recognition and both as
individuals and organizations we should
be fighting against improper usage of
facial recognition
get behind some of the facial
recognition legislation that is being
proposed one example is the commercial
facial recognition Privacy Act of 2019
proposed in Washington DC in which would
prohibit commercial users of facial
recognition technology from collecting
and resharing data or identifying or
tracking customers without their consent
Microsoft president Brad Smith has
spoken out in support of the bill
in the meantime in the absence of solid
laws opt for privacy and be transparent
about the way you allow the use of your
data
[Music]
have you been chipped
implementing chips in humans has privacy
and security implications that go well
beyond cameras in public places facial
recognition tracking of our locations
our driving habits our spending
histories and even Beyond ownership of
your data
this topic touches upon your hand your
heart your brain and the rest of your
body literally
this new development is set to give a
very different meaning to hacking the
body or biohacking while cyber experts
continue to worry about protecting
critical infrastructure and mitigating
security risks that could harm the
economy or cause a loss of life
implanted chips also affect Health but
add in New Dimensions that conflict with
people's religious beliefs
RFID microchips embedded under the skin
with a procedure that's already cheap
and available provide a digital
interface to the real world centered
about the holder's identity credit card
information bus pass library card and
many other sources of information you
currently carry in your personal wallet
and it can instead be stored on an RFID
chip under your skin
however getting chipped could be a way
to control you when guns are paired to
the chips in their owners revolutionary
Heroes can no longer break into their
oppressor's Arsenal to turn their
Firepower against them
putting so much importance on a device
only available to those that seek it out
requires keeping close tabs on its
availability and affordability
if the advantage is effectively
disadvantage those who choose not to
participate gaps between classes May
widen
in a world controlled entirely by chips
within your skin it's possible that
hackers and evildoers could scan and
replicate the data on your chips onto
their own effectively replacing your
physical presence which is notably
different from just stealing digital
credentials
every Hollywood movie has taught us that
implanted microchips are primarily for
Big Brother governments and corporations
to continuously track our every
whereabouts
this is a real concern that needs to be
handled with privacy controls and good
security practices from the get-go
in a world where you purchase food with
the chip in your hand it's not hard to
think that some people might prefer to
use a card in their wallet instead
however it's also not hard to imagine a
world in which the benefits of a
microchip mandate its usage basically
requiring everyone to receive a
microchip or starve lose their job
Etc
one of the benefits of a microchip is
that it's invisible to those who don't
know about it making it harder for
thieves and adversaries to steal your
information
however this Advantage is a double-edged
sword when you consider that people
could potentially be oblivious to
microchips implanted by others in
themselves while sleeping are
unconscious
biblical apocalyptics claim it could be
the mark of the beast indicating the
beginning of Revelations
there is currently no government agency
that oversees or controls neuro-electric
interface enhancements with the closest
body being the FDA due to its broad
jurisdiction over medical devices
the long-term health risks of implanting
microchips in humans is relatively
unknown
on one hand human microchipping has been
green lighted around the world by
various authoritative bodies including
the FDA in America
[Music]
foreign
it may seem we live in a science fiction
World After All We Have a space station
in orbit we've been to the moon and new
Advanced satellites bring us information
from around the planet
but that world could turn out to be a
dystopian Empire where the population is
controlled and herded in line
at the conclusion of the June 1992
United Nations conference on environment
and development and Rio De Janeiro
Brazil President George H.W bush and the
leaders of 177 other nations signed a
document known as agenda 21. at the time
it was seen as a perfectly sensible
planning paper a non-binding statement
of intent aimed at dealing with
sustainability on an increasingly
crowded planet
but in the 22 years since that day at
the hands of groups like the John Birch
Society agent 21 has been transformed in
much of the American public's mind into
a secret plot to impose a totalitarian
World Government a nefarious effort to
crush freedom in the name of
environmentalism
some say Agenda 21 will lead to a new
dark ages of pain and misery yet unknown
to mankind
it is a comprehensive plan of utopian
environmentalism social engineering and
Global political control the most
dangerous threat to America's
sovereignty yet and Technology will make
it possible
it will make our nation a vassal at the
U.N result in the destruction of Our
Lives Force rural areas populations to
be decimated and lead to having 90
percent of the population murdered the
end these critics all agree will be the
imposition of a collectivist world
government
several politicians are aware of the
agenda with state and local authorities
passing legislation to ban it the list
of fears include One World Currency one
religion if any one military no private
property no family units mandatory
vaccines microchips for everyone
social Credit Systems 5G monitoring and
the government raising your children and
controlling all the schools
people would not be able to own cars or
businesses as everything will be managed
either by corporations or governments
[Music]
[Music]
in an agenda 21 world you would have to
be microchipped so the technology could
track you what you buy and where you go
would depend on your compliance with the
agenda
technology would track your every move
with facial recognition microchips
drones and other sophisticated tracing
science
all of the technology needed to do this
is already in play now with more new
technologies being developed every year
we are all moving toward a One World
Government faster than previously
projected
the increasing use of drones for
commercial purposes has become one of
the biggest emerging threats to the
future of airplane safety according to
alanez Global corporate and Specialty
the expected rise in the use of drones
or unmanned aerial vehicles for a host
of different applications may leave
operators exposed to a whole new set of
risks including third-party damage or
injury and liability
one of the biggest risks it said was
from radio frequency interference
resulting in loss of control and in
worst case scenario fatalities the
other problems include invasion of
privacy aerial surveillance and data
collection
privacy Advocates contend that with
drones the government will be able to
engage in widespread pervasive
surveillance because drones are cheaper
to operate than their manned
counterparts
drones are being used by law enforcement
and border control surveillance teams in
case of essential supplies however
drones are not being used exclusively by
Good Guys
in case of natural disasters search and
rescue teams employ them to gather
information or to drop essential
supplies however drones are not being
used exclusively by Good Guys bad guys
are leveraging drones to achieve their
malicious objectives
being easy to control drones can be used
to perform different attacks
[Music]
the Reliance on Wireless Communications
make drones vulnerable to various
attacks these attacks can have drastic
effects including commercial and
non-commercial losses in this context
there is a lack of proper understanding
on how hackers perform their attacks and
hijack a drone in order to intercept it
or even crash it in fact drones can also
be compromised for malicious purposes
hence there is a need to detect them and
prevent them from causing any damage
with a drone you could be followed
anywhere and tracked military drones are
already being deployed on the
battlefield for surveillance it would be
a simple step to bring them home and use
them to track citizens
in August of 2018 a drone-led
assassination attempt was foiled when
two drones wrapped with explosives were
used to assassinate the Venezuelan
president they were shot down by snipers
injuring eight soldiers and one civilian
actually drones are being used by
insurgents and terrorists alike drones
were used by ISIS to drop bombs and to
film propaganda videos in Conflict zones
such as the targeting of Iraq and Syrian
military personnel
being quiet and performing at altitude
you would never know if you were being
observed by a drone
justification for surveillance of
citizens are in court cases now around
the country
[Music]
foreign
weapons are already being used on the
battlefield today the military is always
poised for advanced weapon systems in
developing new weapons yearly
the xm-25 grenade launcher is equipped
with a Laser Rangefinder and onboard
computer it packs a magazine of four 25
millimeter projectiles and programs them
to detonate as they pass by their
targets that feature will allow soldiers
to strike enemies who are taking cover
by 2012 the Army is armed every infantry
Squad and Special Forces Unit with at
least one of the big guns
in August a lucky Soldier got to pull
the trigger and fire off an heab high
explosive air burst round at the
Aberdeen testing ground in Maryland
those projectiles pack quite a punch
they were purposely 300 percent more
effective than normal ammo and will be
able to strike targets as far as 2 300
feet away
foreign
weapons are showing up everywhere Israel
is building an automated Kill Zone an
American firm more Industries offers a
turret that can aim and fire two
automatic shotguns
some robots have been defusing bombs for
years but none have seen combat
according to Lieutenant General Rick
Lynch who believes that 122 men could
have been spared if combat robots had
been working
there was a set of armed robots sent to
Iraq they never fired a shot however
they weren't allowed to no one could
guarantee that the robots wouldn't go
berserk and mow down friendly troops or
otherwise malfunction even though they
have lots of safeguards
considering how much Firepower they pack
safeguards are really important the Mars
system can be equipped with four grenade
launchers and a machine gun that packs
400 rounds of 7.62 caliber ammunition
[Music]
but its manufacturers like to point out
it's less lethal capabilities instead of
mowing people down it can stick to the
fine print of the first law of Robotics
and fire tear gas canisters smoke
grenades smoke bombs and perhaps even
tasers upcoming 40 millimeter people
zapper projectile
three were deployed in Iraq last year
the active denial system fires a beam of
millimeter wave radiation it makes
people feel like their skin is burning
without causing any permanent damage
though promising as a non-lethal weapon
the pain Ray has some serious limits
on a rainy day water droplets will
disperse the beam and it may feel warm
and refreshing instead of frightening on
a hot day the cooling system might give
out the problems don't stop there
raytheon's baby is bulky and despite
repeated requests to send it into battle
shipments of the energy weapon have been
delayed the military is looking for a
strong lighter weapon
if troops spot someone suspicious
approaching them they can use the
long-range acoustic device to send a
warning message it fires narrow beams of
sound waves that can be heard clearly
from about a thousand feet away crank up
the power and it can emit a warning tone
so loud that anyone in its path would
have no choice but to cover their ears
and run
the manufacturer doesn't like to call
these devices weapons even though
they've been used to repel Pirates cops
use them to harass protesters at the G20
Summit in Pittsburgh
drones are arguably the most
controversial weapon in the war on
terror but some accounts they are deeply
feared by the Taliban
they've taken out many Al-Qaeda and
Taliban leaders and their sound when
flying low is a constant annoyance and
reminder of their Menace but they also
kill a lot of civilians
they are however far more cost effective
than supersonic fighter jets Predators
can pack two Hellfire missiles their big
brothers Reapers can hold four hellfires
and up to two 500 pound bombs
flashbang grenades were designed to stun
people but they have a pretty bad safety
record the little bombs have dismembered
at least one soldier and caused hearing
loss in others to remedy that problem
Mark grubelich and his colleagues at
Sandia National Laboratory built the
improved flashbang grenade it hurls
flaming aluminum particles into the air
causing a bright flash without an
accompanying shock wave
even the angriest mobs would probably
think twice about trying to pass a taser
Shockwave barrier it's the less lethal
equivalent of a Claymore Mine push the
big red button and it will fire 24
electrified probes at the same time in a
single Direction
[Music]
after learning about an experimental
weapon that can make people feel seasick
the more fried in Phil tomor decided to
build their own they did it for less
than 250 dollars and wrote step-by-step
instructions so anyone can make one at
home it can cause a nauseating light
show with 36 pulsating LEDs
[Music]
now if you're worried that someone's
about to attack you but not completely
sure of their intent it's a good idea to
give them a warning before pulling the
trigger green laser pointers are a great
way to extend that courtesy the Marines
like to call them ocular Interruption
devices
shine one in someone's face and your
target should immediately get the
message that it's time to back off
the la-9p made by B.E Myers can warn
people from up to two and a half miles
away it fires a 250 milliwatt beam
that's roughly one-fourth the strength
of the smallest anti-aircraft lasers
even so you've got to be careful when
handling the thing over a few months in
Iraq a dozen soldiers were wounded in
dazzler Friendly Fire several troops may
have been injured while monkeying around
with laser target disintegrators which
are substantially more powerful than the
less lethal devices
and behold the laser Adventure a cannon
that can be used to take down incoming
aircraft Boeing was able to shoot a
drone out of the sky with a Hummer
mounted laser even though it's not
particularly high powered it cooked the
remote control aircraft using a somewhat
feeble one kilowatt beam
more recently the company shot down
another UAV using a low power laser
paired with its mobile active targeting
resource for integrated experiments or
Matrix system during a test in White
Sands New Mexico
Northrop Grumman is hard at work on a
100 kilowatt laser weapon which could do
far more damage but it's not quite ready
for prime time it's fully operational
but looks like a refrigerator
Boeing announced in December that the
Avenger has been used to destroy 50
different improvised explosive devices
during tests at Redstone Arsenal in
Huntsville Alabama
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
science fiction has always been a medium
for futuristic imagination and while
different colored aliens and
Intergalactic travel are yet to be
discovered there is an array of
technologies that are no longer figments
of the imagination thanks to the world
of science fiction
some of the creative inventions that
have appeared in family favorite movies
like Back to the Future and Total Recall
are now at the Forefront of modern
technology
while exploring space characters such as
Captain Kirk and Spock would come across
alien life who spoke a different
language to understand the galactic
foreigners the Star Trek characters used
a device that immediately translated the
alien's unusual language
Star Trek's Universal Communicator was
first seen on screen as spot tampered
with it in order to communicate with a
non-biological entity
although the idea in Star Trek was to
communicate with intelligent alien life
a device capable of breaking down
language barriers would revolutionize
real-time communication
now products such as Source necks pocket
talk and skype's new voice translation
services are capable of providing
instantaneous translation between
languages
Flawless real-time communication is far
off but the technological advancements
over the last decade mean this feat is
Within Reach
the idea behind beaming someone up was
that a person could be broken down into
an energy form and then converted back
into matter at their destination
transporting people this way on Star
Trek's USS Enterprise had been around
since the very beginning of the series
debuting in the pilot episode
scientists haven't figured out how to
transport humans yet but they can
teleport balls of energy known as
photons in this case teleportation is
based on a phenomenon known as quantum
entanglement
this refers to a condition in quantum
mechanics where two entangled particles
may be very far from one another yet
remain connected so that actions
performed on One affect the other
regardless of distance the information
exchange between the two photons occurs
at least ten thousand times faster than
the speed of light
not long into the first Star Wars movie
Obi-Wan Kenobi receives a holographic
message by definition a hologram is a 3D
image created from the interference of
light beams from a laser onto 2D
surfaces and can only be seen in one
angle
foreign
researchers from Brigham Young
University in Utah created a real
hologram their technique called
volumetric display works like an
Etch-a-Sketch toy but uses particles at
high speeds with lasers researchers can
trap particles and move them into a
designated shape while another set of
lasers emit red green and blue light
into the particle and create an image
but so far this can only happen on
extremely small scales
after losing his hand Luke Skywalker
receives a bionic version that has all
the functions of a normal hand this
scenario is now more feasible than the
previous one
researchers from the Georgia University
of Technology in Atlanta Georgia have
been developing a way for amputees to
control each of their prosthetic fingers
using an ultrasonic sensor
in the movie Skywalker's prosthesis uses
electromagnetic sensors attached to his
muscles the sensors can be switched into
different modes and are controlled by
the flexing or Contracting of his
muscles the prosthesis created by the
Georgia Tech researchers however uses
machine learning and ultrasound signals
to detect fine Finger by finger movement
orbiting Earth in 2001 A Space Odyssey
is space station v a large establishment
located in low earth orbit where
astronauts can Bounce Around in
microgravity
does this sound familiar the space
station B provided inspiration for the
International Space Station which has
been orbiting the Earth since 1998 and
currently accommodates up to six
astronauts at a time
although space station B appears much
more luxurious the ISS has accomplished
much more science the ISS has been
fundamental in microgravity research
since the start of its construction in
1998.
tablets are wonderful handheld computers
that can be controlled at the Press of a
finger these handy devices are used by
people across the globe and even further
upwards in the International Space
Station
Apple claims to have invented the tablet
with the release of its iPad however
Samsung made an extremely interesting
case in court that Apple was wrong
Stanley Kubrick and Sir Arthur C Clarke
did it by including the device in the
movie 2001 A Space Odyssey released in
1968. in the film Dr David Bowman and Dr
Frank Poole watch news updates from
their flat screen computers which they
called newspads Samsung claimed that
these news pads were the original tablet
featured in a film over 40 years before
the first iPad arrived in 2010
foreign
to an actual warp drive for space travel
an ion Thruster or ion drive is a form
of electric propulsion used for
spacecraft propulsion it creates thrust
by accelerating ions using electricity
this engine was used on Deep Space 1 and
the dawn NASA spacecraft
a plasma propulsion engine is a type of
electric propulsion that generates
thrust from a quasi-neutral plasma
While most plasma engines are still
combined to the laboratory some have
been actively flying and used on
missions
as of 2011 NASA partnered with the
Aerospace company Busick and launched
the first hall effect Thruster aboard
the tassat 2 satellite the Thruster was
the satellite's main propulsion system
actual warp drive is still far into the
future but as more of these Advanced
propulsion systems are developed the
idea is not only feasible but now we
know it can actually be done
shrouded in mystery the existence of a
secret space program is a closely
guarded secret but information from
government whistleblowers intelligence
operatives and former astronauts have
been servicing for decades
in 2020 America launched the space force
a new branch of the U.S military along
with the Air Force the new space force
will be in charge of all military needs
in outer space
many question the need for such a
program we already had the space command
Department of the Air Force some
speculate the need may be a fear of
extraterrestrial Invasion or influence
on the planet
technology already exists for the new
space force to take over for example the
X-37B space plane is now in use
much like the old space shuttles the
X-37B can be tasked with several secret
missions though it is unmanned or so we
are told
the strange thing about this space plane
is that its mission is top secret no one
apart from a tiny handful of top
military experts know what the aircraft
is tasked to do
what we do know is that the aircraft
also known as an orbital test vehicle
will deploy a satellite into orbit and
also test power beaming technology
the small plane is unmanned which means
there are no astronauts on board the
vehicle it is controlled remotely from
Earth
[Music]
it is able to fly back down to earth and
land on a Runway like a standard
airplane meaning it can be relaunched
over and over
the Pentagon a top military building
where America's most senior military
officials work has revealed very few
details about the aircraft's missions in
the past
although it is often referred to as a
spy plane the U.S Air Force has never
confirmed if the rocket is monitoring
other countries or satellites
some experts have previously said it
would be difficult to monitor other
satellites it should be noted also that
China has a secret space vehicle but
little is known about it
we may never know what the secret
mission really is
but the secret space program goes much
deeper than just one spy plane
rumors have persisted for decades that
the USA has such a program allegedly it
began after the Roswell incident when
America came into possession of alien
technology
there are those who claim we have
already been to the moon in the 1950s
and the NASA program was only for public
consumption
whistleblowers have said we have time
travel technology we've been to Mars and
there is even a base on the moon and
Mars
further down the rabbit hole is rumors
that we actually fought a war with
aliens and the secret space program is
in place to protect us from them
with Russian inspector satellites
largely believed to be orbitable weapons
platforms and China now beginning to
field its own maneuverable unmanned
orbital platforms that can also be used
to disrupt our Nation's satellite
capabilities it's clear today the United
States is finding ways to fight future
Wars in space at least as far as
non-classified programs go
foreign
[Music]
despite harsh statements made by both
Russian and Chinese government officials
regarding America's space force each of
those Nations has already maintained
space-based branches of their own for
years
in fact even America once had a
secretive Department of Defense Space
Program complete with its own military
astronauts a 3.3 billion dollar
california-based Spaceport meant for
secretive space shuttle launches into
Polar orbit and more
the Endeavor was called the manned space
flight Engineer program and although it
hasn't gotten much attention in the
years since the Pentagon invested
billions of dollars into it throughout
the 1970s and 80s a secret group of 32
men was selected from the U.S Air Force
and trained as astronauts completely
independent of their peers at Nasa the
specialized training revolved around
deploying classified payloads and
conducting other secretive activities in
orbit using America's space shuttle as
the primary orbital platform in fact at
one time the dod intended to fly more
subtle flights per year than NASA
black star is the reported code name of
a secret United States orbital space
plane system the possible existence of
the Black Star program was reported in
March of 2006 by Aviation week and space
technology magazine the magazine
reported that the program had been
underway since at least the early 1990s
and that the impetus for Blackstar was
to allow the United States government to
retain orbital reconnaissance
capabilities jeopardized following the
1986 Challenger disaster
the article also said the United States
Air Force space command was unaware of
black star suggesting it was operated by
an intelligence agency or some other
secret space program
Aviation week speculated that such a
spacecraft could also have offensive
military capabilities a concept
colloquially known as the space bomber
the magazine also stated that it was
likely that black star would be
mothballed although it is unclear
whether this is due to a cost or failure
of the program
a secret space program was revealed to
the worldwide public following
allegations against Gary McKinnon for
hacking the U.S defense programs in
2002.
in an interview televised on the BBC
McKinnon stated that he was able to get
into the military's Network
simply by using a computer code familiar
to computer administrators
in his interview with the BBC he also
stated of the disclosure project that
they are some very credible relied upon
people all saying yes there is UFO
technology there's anti-gravity there's
free energy and it's extraterrestrial in
origin and they've captured spacecraft
and reverse engineered it
he said he investigated a NASA
photographic expert's claim that at the
Johnson Space Center's building 8 images
were regularly cleaned of evidence of
UFO craft and he confirmed this
comparing the raw Originals with the
processed images
he stated to have viewed a detailed
image of something not man-made and
cigar-shaped floating above the Northern
Hemisphere assuming his viewing would be
undisrupted owing to the hour he did not
think of capturing the image because he
was bedazzled and therefore did not
think of securing it with a screen
capture function in the software at the
point when his connection was
interrupted
McKinnon described the cigar-shaped
spacecraft in rudimentary terms but with
some notable features that paralleled
other Witnesses description of an
existing cylindrical spacecraft
one of the most interesting things about
this was a Microsoft Excel spreadsheet
he came across with 20 to 30 names of
government officials that was titled
non-terrestrial officers
what's more intriguing according to
reports McKinnon also discovered an
unusual list of U.S Navy vessels but
cross-checking against the active list
of surface ships and submarines McKinnon
could not find those names on the
current U.S Navy roster what does this
mean
the list of non-terrestrial officers is
alleged by many UFO researchers to be
the names of U.S Navy and Air Force
officers who are serving on ships off
the Earth
that's to say they are assigned to
interplanetary vessels
Additionally the names of the ships that
he found are actually the names of
interplanetary spaceships
currently in service
is it possible we have an active
interplanetary space force already being
utilized for the protection of Earth
we certainly have the technology to
build and maintain such a force the key
would be in the billions allocated to
the dark military budget in the USA
with enough money you could build
several fleets and the black budget has
plenty
technology has the power to do many
things and changing the world is one of
them
we're privileged to live in a time where
Science and Technology can assist us
make our lives easier and rethink the
ways we go about our daily lives
the technology we're already exposed and
accustomed to has paved the way for us
to innovate further and this list of
current and future Technologies
certainly have the potential to change
our lives even more
we may even be closer to that flying car
you were promised as a child
they do exist today
however with all Innovations it will
depend on what we do with them they can
either enhance our lives and make the
world a better place to live or we may
find ourselves in a dystopian future
where we are ruled and controlled by the
very Technologies we rely on
that is up to us and how we manage an
ever-changing world with advanced
technology
[Music]
foreign
[Music]